hi guys good morning this is Luca from
Luca Lombardo calm and today we're going
to have a kind of different video we are
going to answer your questions the way I
did it before remind you all the
questions have collected are in English
but at the end of the video I will ask
you to ask more questions and you can
ask them in any language you want as far
as as long as I actually know these
languages and I can reply it without
further ado let's get started and let's
read the first question
which is by Jonathan Quiros and Luca and
pudendal it's great to see your videos
thank you I saw one of your videos about
how to get from b2 to c1 and one of your
tips is to read a bilingual books but I
don't have a bilingual book that is why
I bought two books of the same version I
guess it here you want to say the two
versions of the same book do you have a
good method or of how I can study them
in an effective way you didn't specify
the language you are actually currently
learning so I don't know but depending
on the language some languages are more
popular than others and it's easier to
find bilingual books that would be the
ultimate resource because you have both
versions of both languages on two
different pages and you can actually
compare but in case you cannot find such
resources because maybe you're learning
a language that is not very popular you
can always buy the same book in two
different languages in your language and
in the target language and how do you go
about that well you can for example read
the entire book in your native language
so that you get an idea of the contents
of the entire book and then you can read
the book again in your target language
but I would not take this route I would
rather have a more modular approach
where you can actually compare smaller
pieces of content just to give an
example you could read one paragraph in
your target language and read one
paragraph in your native language or the
other way around so that you can compare
the two paragraphs or you can compare
two chapters or you can compare one page
with the other I would normally use
the page as your piece of content that
you in which you can compare the two
languages and you can use a a pencil so
that whenever you compare comparing with
your own native language will help you
figure out the meaning of the words but
also the structure of the sentences so
this is my piece of advice and I think
it's a very good thing to have a book in
two different languages if you cannot
find a bilingual book on to the next
question by Suk
Tao Lucca why I can't speak English
until right now I've been watching
YouTube all day long and still cannot
speak when I face native I guess
speakers is my expectation wrong or the
language does not work like that please
answer my problem and this is what I'm
doing right now so you can spend the
whole day watching YouTube listening to
English and reading English but you have
to remember that speaking listening
writing and reading are four different
skills and if you think about it you
learn and absorb them you develop these
skills through five full of different
channels which are your eyes your ears
your hand and your mouth so you can
spend a lot of time listening and a lot
of time reading which is great its input
but that is going to help you speak just
to a certain degree if you want to speak
you have to speak you have to remember
that if you want to develop what we we
call it speaking a language actually
speaking the language is a combination
of four sub skills and these skills have
themselves other skills again it's
reading listening speaking and writing
if you want to develop your language
skills in an organic way you better
develop all these skills so on top of
reading and listening to comprehensible
and interesting content which you're
probably already doing what I suggest is
that you start speaking possibly with
native speakers on skype or native
speakers in real life if you have the
chance and also writing because the
combination of impo
and output is key you cannot expect to
develop great language skills or better
speaking language skills if you do not
speak I hope I replied to your question
so get to it speak as much as you can
find your gaps and then move on and
progress in the language it's not that
difficult it's just a matter of making
it happen
another question by Luciano Coleman
Addis I guess he is Portuguese of
Brazilian I look I found this video very
interesting and instructive as all the
videos to make for us again thank you
for all the nice words I have some
questions regarding the position of our
body while learning does it influence
the way you learn and if so what other
factors can influence us on our learning
process I found this topic really
interesting and I'd like to know your
opinion about it thinks in advance Luka
yes I think this is a very interesting
topic it's an often neglected we often
focus on learning how to learn what
happens while we hit the books so to
speak but what happens before we start
hitting the books is also very important
so that's the reason why I also recently
made videos about setting up having the
proper setup to learn languages I think
that there's a number of factors that
influence our ability not only to learn
but also to focus and to our energy our
concentration first where you learn that
is really important it can be a desktop
or your place it can be at your work but
that does influence your learning if you
are in an environment that in which a
lot of people distract you all the time
that's not a very good environment so
that's the reason why I always wake up
early in the morning and hit the books
so to speak as soon as I can
in my own room where I know nobody is
gonna who's gonna get inside and at
least until 8 o'clock in the morning
that's the reason why I wake up early
that's also another important factor
when do you learn I always make sure
that I learn when I am relatively fresh
and my energy is I that is in the
morning so in my room in the morning
where nobody disturbs me but there's
another important thing to keep in mind
and it is how I am actually dressed as
of now I'm dressed in the you know
filming mode or a working mode and the
clothes that you wear do play a role as
weird as it may sound in the way we
learn we approach others you know when
you're dressed really well have you ever
felt like oh I'm dressed really well it
makes you a little bit more confident
especially if you have to give a
presentation or at a job interview
that's reason why it also works when it
comes to learning when I wake up of
course I'm in my pajamas but I make sure
that I get dressed you know as if I were
to walk out because that also influences
my mood and my capacity of focusing
better and if I'm more focused I learn a
better as a consequence of that also
another thing to keep in mind is the
position of your body so again I'm here
and as you can see what I normally do I
have my computer but I also use paper so
I put my computer on one side I put
paper on the other side I use the
computer mostly for listening so I put
it there but I don't actually use it
unless I have to use audio material but
the position of my body this kind of
position with the computer and with a
piece of paper allows me to actually
manage to move from the digital digital
to the real world and I can manage the
two with two different hands they also
and the other I would say elements that
influences our learning is actually the
tools that we're learning and that's
important if you're using a piece of
paper you're probably going to be a
little bit more focus than if you were
hopping from video to video on on the
Internet I always say that the internet
gives you speed and gives you access to
resources while a piece of paper gives
you depth and helps you focus more so
also the tools that you learn actually
do influence the way you learn it's a
combination of these factors so you can
experiment with these five six factors
and see what works best for you but
again to answer your question everything
all those small details even the details
that you would think are trivial account
in your capacity of learning staying
focused and absorbing of
Meishan KO 4 5 3 6 Lucca is on easy
languages quite often there are 10
minute videos so instead of fervently
searching for three four minute videos
why not divide it into three four
sessions that's a very good question or
observation and I have done this
recently especially when learning Greek
what I normally do if I find I found a
very good channel which is called Astro
neo in Greek but it has very lengthy
videos of 12 minutes are packed with
information and sometimes I just don't
have the time to go through the video
the way I would like to go through the
video not just watching it but re
watching it taking notes etc so a 10 11
or 12 minute video becomes a 40 minute
training exercise that's the reason why
I break it down into three minute
snippets so I divide it into three parts
and that's much easier for me because if
I have a snippet of say three minutes I
can focus on that that becomes maybe a
twenty or thirty minute training
exercise where I can do a number of
things a number of steps watching it
listening to it taking notes grabbing a
vocab etc etc and I can break it down
into three different days so your
question or observation is is to the
point if you find something that is too
long but it's really interesting well
why not break it down into easier and
shorter versions or snippets that you
can digest better
Luigi zombie this is easy to pronounce
have you read every book on these behind
you unfortunately I don't have right now
I'm in another location within my room
so you cannot see my bookshelves but the
reality is that recently I've been
telling myself that for every ten books
I buy then I read just one so I'm buying
many more books that I actually have
time to read and that's fine I know that
I will read all of them or almost all of
them but the truth is I
haven't read all of them because they
keep piling up having said that I think
one of the Year New Year's resolution is
to stop buying books focus on a few
books that are important for me both for
my business for my education and then I
can start buying books again on a final
note reading is really important it can
change your life and if you can read on
a piece of paper you can actually read
books like that were printed it will
help you also
not only practice your reading skills
but also practice your focus because
reading a book in plain silence is a
revolutionary act of these days and it's
some kind of it's a yeah I would call it
I will call it revolutionary just many
many more and more people have just
abandoned reading books and I think it's
important but something important to do
now on to the next question what kind of
advice by Crom f66 8 what kind of advice
would you give someone who works 80 plus
hours a week and only gets an average
about four hours of sleep a day I've
been trying to learn Russian now for
seller ears I'm still just a beginner I
just cannot get things to stick to my
memory well the first thing that comes
to mind is that you should work less and
sleep a little bit more I know that it
sounds trivial but I think that I I have
myself have been working a little bit
too much and I told myself you know what
you have to scale back because health is
really important and also recently read
a very interesting book which is called
a why we sleep by Jeff Walker who talks
about the importance of sleeping so if
you work 80 hours maybe there's a
possibility if there's a chance of
reducing your working hours maybe
because you've become a workaholic or
because you know because of a number of
reasons I think you should invest time
on figuring out a way to reduce these
hours and then you get more time to
yourself and dedicating more time to
yourself means sleeping better eating
better and learning better so if you
have time if you create this mental time
or this physical time for the matter you
have actually more hours or more min
to dedicate to language Rory you can
wake up in the morning and dedicate 30
minutes a day to your Russian or you can
do it in the evening this allows you to
create a space where again learning
every single day plays a major role and
the other thing that comes to my mind
here in your comment is that you said I
just cannot get things to stick to my
memory with very little sleep your your
memory is just gonna you're just gonna
get worse and worse because memory is
directly connected with sleeping
patterns and that's also one other good
reason why you not only should find ways
to learn the Russian in a better way
there's hundreds of methods but I think
that there's an underlying problem of
getting more sleep and I would start
with that and if you create this mental
time then you have time and energy and
the concentration necessary to explore
and experiment new ways of learning
Russia but again if you want to learn
Russian apart from changing a few habits
of your life you have to stick to it in
the long run so sticking to it even
fifteen or thirty minutes a day is
really really important and you can only
do that if you get enough sleep you eat
well you open the window in the morning
and say it's a beautiful day and it's
time to learn Russian the next question
is by Mele Fit Luca how would you
recommend practice in a language like
modern Standard Arabic where the
language itself is not spoken in homes
but only in professional settings he
makes the language process a tad bit
more difficult one of the reasons why I
have been procrastinating when it comes
to learning Arabic is that I got the
impression and I recently asked this on
Facebook I've asked for help for those
who - to those who know Arabic in some
of its dialects or its
local versions as I call it is what -
starts from modern Arabic or the local
diet dialect because as it goes as truth
goes it turns out that modern Arabic is
just an artificial language or maybe not
an artificial language but an official
language that is
and the media in literature but is not
something that people actually use on
the street so my answer here is if you
want to practice a standard modern
Standard Arabic money and well I would
say just try to watch and listen to
material in Standard Arabic and also
talk to Skype with native native Arabic
speakers who surely know are educated
speakers and you can speak speak the
language you can practice the language
with them this is what I would do if I
one day and I will it's on the to-do
list I will start learning Arabic I
think I will I will both learn Standard
Arabic and a local dialect and I don't
know still don't know which one I should
start from first but I think you can
always practice the language because
there's so many resources out there so
so that's I hope that answers your
question
Luka John young Chuck I've been studying
Danish myself for a while now and I'm
wondering what resources you're using
and might recommend this is pretty fresh
because I've been learning Danish myself
for one month and a half or two months
and I'm using a single Danish with ease
in the French version so this is this is
easy to to reply I've been learning
Danish I've been learning with Danish
ASIMO Danish with ease the French
version I don't know if there is a
version in English for sure there's no
version in Italian so I'm learning it
from French which is a great advantage
knowing English and French and then I
would say Danish pod 101 I have
downloaded everything I think it's a
great resource I haven't started yet but
I will because my strategy is always
that of finishing absorbing one resource
before moving on to another resource and
the third thing I'm using for my
motivation is on and off watching in
some videos on YouTube especially you
see Danish you have this fantastic
series in all languages are almost all
European languages easy Danish easy
French easy Spanish but I think the
great thing about that is not only does
it show you know how people actually
talk on the street because there's
someone you know with a microphone going
around and asking questions and to
random random questions to random people
so you get to see how people actually
speak in real life but it's also great
for your motivation because when you see
you have audio-visual material and you
actually see how people interact you see
the environment you see Denmark
you see you know when they talk about
they use slang they talk about customary
success customers etc you really
motivates you and I'm using the
combination at a combination of these
three resources obviously I'm still a
beginner even if truth be told I do
speak Swedish which helps and sometimes
gets in the way but I will use a
combination of these three resources
until you feel but you've gotten a good
level and you're ready to use another
batch of resources there's a lot of
stuff out there Matthew Davis asked me
Luca would you make a video specifically
about how you use I talk I Skype lessons
so effectively do you plan ahead to make
sure the teachers speaks only in the
target language etc etc it's a very
interesting question and I will make a
video about that but for the sake of
simplicity and brave and brevity I would
say that first I talkie is a great
platform because it allows you to find
teachers in any language and you can
find your own teacher and but how you
use it obviously how you use I talk I
talk I lessons is really important I
normally have I think an envisioned
three phases phase number one is
preparation phase number two is the
actual talking or execution as I call it
and phase number three is reviewing so I
always make sure that I record the
lesson that I prepare a topic beforehand
there's a lot of ways to prepare a
lesson and I train my students in my
coaching lessons to do just that and
then you have to lesson maybe 30 minutes
45 minutes and then make sure that you
record the lessons that you can review
it and here again there's a lot of
interesting
strategies to make sure that the
information that you learn during the
class during the lesson is retained you
retain it in the long term and another
question but Matthew Davis if you don't
mind if you don't mind asking what do
you do about all your other languages so
I guess that this question is related to
the fact that I am currently learning
three languages at the same time
Danish Greek and Hungarian and so
Matthew probably you're asking me what
happens what the heck do you do for
though the outer languages that you
speak because I often say that I've been
learning fourteen languages that's let's
put it this way I have fourteen
languages in my arsenal even if you know
Danish is a language I still cannot
speak it takes a long time to explain
what I do in detail but again to to put
it shortly in a nutshell I have built a
lifestyle which allows me to practice a
number of languages on a daily basis and
it all comes it all comes down to
choices in life at a certain point of my
life I told myself that yes being an
engineer is cool I have I do have a
degree in electronic engineering but
communicating talking about language
learning traveling conferences living
and breathing languages would have
allowed me to actually use these
languages much more than if I had I
don't know chosen another career so I
have made a number of choices a number
of decisions which have allowed me to do
just that speaking a bunch of languages
on a daily basis for example I live with
foreigners it's not that I am disgusted
by Italians it's not that I like
Italians it's just that it's a it's a
consistent choice to live with
foreigners which allows me allows me to
practice languages on a daily basis the
languages I've been practicing in the
last two years in my own apartment are
Italian English French Spanish the
German Russian polish
Dutch just to give an example so it's
just eight languages right now I can use
a three to four languages on a daily
basis the second is to choose a job that
has to do I chose a job that has to do
with languages so I give coaching
sessions in multiple combinations I can
give a coaching session to an American
wants to learn Italian or French or
German and there's a lot of them or a
lot of Italians who want to learn
English French German or other languages
so this allows me to give coaching
sessions on how to learn languages in a
lot of combinations in multiple
languages so it allows me once again to
practice languages at a very high level
on a daily basis and third I have built
a number of habits in my micro
environment that is in my apartment and
outside of my apartment which allow me
to learn and progress and make progress
in a bunch of languages everyday just to
give an example when I go to the kitchen
and they cook around 1:00 2:00 p.m. I
always make sure that I listen to
something either in Russian or in Polish
and I've built this I've basically
associated the act of cooking and eating
afterwards with the act of listening to
a language which is a little bit weaker
than the others like Russian or polish
or Hungarian for that matter and I have
a set of habits which allow me to
practice these languages listen read
even speak on a daily basis this allows
me to keep using these languages
obviously there are languages that I do
not use as much for example Swedish or
Mandarin Chinese or Japanese for that
matter are languages that are a little
bit in the background you have to
imagine like having 14 languages like
having 14 friends and you cannot see
them all you know you cannot dedicate
the same amount of time to all of them
sometimes they're closer to you for a
number of circumstances some friends and
some others are in the background you
see them less often and sometimes the
other friends in the background they
come to you for because circumstances
changed so it happens and it will happen
the Japanese and Mandarin will knock on
the door and say a Luka we haven't
talked in a long time why not you know
start chatting again anyway Quan and
race says Luka dot how do you treat with
procrastination
I guess you means how do you deal with
procrastination and my answer is that
like everybody else I do procrastinate
in a lot of things that is only natural
because our mind we are Homo almost
sapiens and we have the same brain that
we had 200,000 years ago or maybe even
more and 200,000 years ago we didn't
have the problem right now you know I
can go to the fridge I can open the
fridge and get some food I don't need to
venture into some wasteland or some
forest where some tiger is gonna eat me
and the reason why I'm telling you this
is because we have a natural tendency of
saving energy and procrastinating
because that's our biology so I do
procrastinate like everybody else but
I've put some let's say some mechanisms
in motion or I've I want I have to have
some mechanisms in place to avoid a
procrastinating just to give an example
and language learning I procrastinate a
little bit less because first I love it
and second I've built a system which
allows me to learn on a daily basis so I
wake up I do my bed and then do or make
my bed and then I just sit down and and
hit the books
I do not procrastinate because I know
that that's the very first thing I'm
gonna do in the morning so first of all
you can buy it you can create a system
where you know that at a specific time
of the day you're gonna do that so no
questions asked you're just gonna do
that but another thing is to have
post-its I've figured out that you have
post-its and if you remind yourself of
doing stuff well that kind of helps of
getting into the habit of doing things
and another thing that I do in order to
avoid procrastinating or reduce
procrastinating because I think that
it's impossible to eliminate
procrastinating
in general and all completely is to
count from five to one or from one to
five and tell yourself that no matter
what happens even if it made meteorite
falls on earth you're going to do what
you were set to do you know like that if
you can train yourself even when you
wake up and say oh my god I have to get
out of bed count from file2 one and no
matter what happens just stand up and if
you do that you train your brain to do
things even when you don't feel like
doing that we have motivation backwards
we think the motivation or the will of
doing something is going to fall from
the sky and all of a sudden we're going
to feel motivated but the reality is
that you have to start doing something
you have to overcome that obstacle that
moment when your mind tells you don't do
that if you do that you will see you'll
get in the flow and you'll actually like
doing that for example I don't know
today I'm really excited about making
this video but let's suppose that I was
not excited once once I start actually
filming I get into the flow so it what
would you really have to focus on and
train your mind is just overcome that
those five seconds ten seconds where you
don't feel like something dis applies to
language learning and anything else in
life if you learn to do that your life
is gonna get much much better in any
field Luca B Luca okay what do you think
how many times you approximately have to
see word in different contexts to
remember it and I'm really interested in
your Frank opinion of gold list method
this is the last question and I would
say that the more times you get exposed
to a word the better meaning that the
more time the the more you read you
listen you recently you listen and read
you watch stuff you speak the language
yourself the more probable it is going
to become that you're going to get
exposed to this language and that you're
going to use I'm sorry that you're going
to get exposed to this specific word and
that you're going to use it so I don't
think you should you should ask yourself
how many times you have to do that
because everybody works everybody's
brain works in a different way the only
thing I can tell is that you have a set
of words within the vast vocab in a
language that we tend to use all the
time and if you read listen again read
and listen watch stuff a ton of stuff
massively and then you also use the
language and that word is going to be is
going to happen is going to appear
somewhere you're gonna use it and your
brain is gonna absorb it the more angles
of attack you have are the better
so actually sometimes language learning
is a simple matter you have to get
massive input because that massive input
is great for your conscious and
unconscious part of your mind and you
have to use the language so that you
actually learn to use that word from
another perspective you have to remember
that when we use the term word what is a
word let's take the word game right I
always use this word game because it's a
particularly interesting one a word has
costs a lot of it's called polysemic can
have a lot of meanings depending on
context can have different functions can
have different connotations so it's
actually a simplistic way when we talk
about Oh what does it mean to to learn a
word to know a word a word has a lot of
different aspects and facets that you
learn with time that's what kids do and
what we do for that matter as native
speakers we tend to see this word and
use this word and hear different
connotations and meanings through a lot
of exposure so again instead of asking
yourself how many times you should see
this or hear this or do that
just get massive exposure to the
language and use the language as much as
you can ask questions when you look up
this word maybe look up different
meanings and contests of this word
because a word is a complex entity and
you need to absorb its various facets
little by little in
long run so there you have it I hope
that these replies were useful for you
and interesting and I'm going to do this
more often
please write and drop a bunch of
comments in the comment section below
and ask your questions mmm this this
video has been mainly in English I've
collected all the questions in English
now replied just English but to make
this even more interesting and like you
did back in the day we can make this
video multilingual so please ask the
questions in any language you want but
keep in mind that I know 13 or 12 of
them so I will reply in the languages
that I know I again I really hope that
you found this this video useful and I
wish you a fantastic a and see you in
YouTube very soon bye
[Music]